تلقي الاضطرابات الاقتصاديه وتداعيه جائحه
كورونا تلقي بثقالها على الاقتصاد العالمي
لتاتي الحرب في اوكرانيا العام الحالي
لتزيد الطين بالله اذا توقع مؤتمر الامم
المتحده للتجاره والتنميه ان تفقد وتيره
نشاط النقل البحري العالمي زخمها العام
المقبل وتشير تقيمات اكبر لاكبر البنوك
الاستثماريه في العالم الى ان نمو
الاقتصاديه العالمي سيشهدوا مزيدا من
التباط ايه في عام 2023 ومن المتوقع ان
يؤثر التباطؤ على الملاحه البحريه التي
تنقل اكثر من 80% من التجاره المتداوله
عالميا الا ان رسوم الشحن بالناقلات قد
تظل مرتفعه تقرير المؤتمر توقع تراجع
النمو في التجاره البحريه العالميه الى
واحد الفصل اربعه بالمئه هذا العام وان
يظل عند النفس المستوى في 2023 ما يشير
الى احتماليه العوده عام 2021 حيث دفع
زياده الانفاق الاستهلاكي اسواق الشحن
بالحاويات الى مستويات قياسيه وادت الى
تكدس في الموانئ في انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]